[Music]
so i'm a woman with chronic
schizophrenia i've spent hundreds of
days in psychiatric hospitals
i might have ended up spending most of
my life on the backward of a hospital
but that isn't how my life turned out
in fact i've managed to stay clear of
hospitals for almost three decades
perhaps my proudest accomplishment
that's not to say that i've remained
clear of all psychiatric struggles after
i graduated from the yale law school and
got my first law job my new haven
analyst dr white announced to me that he
was going to close his practice in three
months several years before i had
planned to leave new haven
white had been enormously helpful to me
and the thought of his leaving
shattered me
my best friend steve sensing that
something was terribly wrong flew out to
new haven to be with me now i'm going to
quote from some of my writings
i opened the door to my studio apartment
steve would later tell me that for all
the times he had seen me psychotic
nothing could have prepared him for what
he saw that day
for a week or more i had barely eaten
i was gaunt i walked as though my legs
were wooden
my face looked and felt like a mask
i had closed all the curtains in the
apartment so in the middle of the day
the apartment was in near total darkness
the air was fed the room of shambles
steve both a lawyer and a psychologist
has treated many patients with severe
mental illness and to this day he'll say
i was as bad as any he had ever seen hi
i said and then i returned to the couch
where i sat in silence for several
moments
thank you for coming steve
crumbling world
word
voice tell the clocks to stop time is
time has come
white is leaving steve said somberly i'm
being pushed into a grave the situation
is grave i moan gravity is pulling me
down
i'm scared tell them to get away
as a young woman i was in a psychiatric
hospital on three different occasions
for lengthy periods my doctors diagnosed
me with chronic schizophrenia and gave
me a prognosis of quote grave that is at
best i was expected to live in aborted
care and work at menial jobs
fortunately i did not actually enact
that grave prognosis instead i'm a chair
professor of law psychology and
psychiatry at the usc guild school of
law i have many close friends and i have
a beloved husband will who's here with
us today
thank you
[Music]
he's he's definitely the star of my show
i'd like to share with you how that
happened and also describe my experience
of being psychotic i hasten to add that
it's my experience because everyone
becomes psychotic in his or her own way
let's start with the definition of
schizophrenia schizophrenia is a brain
disease it's defining future a psychosis
or being out of touch with reality
delusions and hallucinations are
hallmarks of the illness delusions are
fixed and false beliefs that aren't
responsive to evidence and
hallucinations are false sensory
experiences
for example when i'm a psychotic i often
have the delusion that i've killed
hundreds of thousands of people with my
thoughts i sometimes have the idea that
nuclear explosions are about to be set
off in my brain
occasionally i have hallucinations like
one time i turned around and saw a man
with a raised knife
imagine having a nightmare while you're
awake
often speech and thinking become
disorganized to the point of incoherence
loose associations involves putting
together words that may sound a lot
alike but don't make sense and if the
words get jumbled up enough it's called
word salad
contrary to what many people think
schizophrenia is not the same as
multiple personality disorder or split
personality the schizophrenic mind is
not split but shattered
everyone has seen a street person
unkempt probably ill-fed standing
outside of an office building muttering
to himself or shouting this person is
likely to have some form of
schizophrenia but schizophrenia presents
itself across a wide array of
socioeconomic status and there are
people with the illness who are
full-time professionals with major
responsibilities
several years ago i decided to write
down my experiences and my personal
journey and i want to share some more of
that story with you today to convey the
inside view
so the following episode happened the
seventh week of my first semester of my
first year at yale law school quoting
from my writings
my two classmates rebel and val and i
had made the date to work to meet in the
law school library on friday night to
work on our memo assignment together but
we didn't get far before i was talking
in ways that made no sense
memos or visitations i inform them they
make certain points the point is on your
head pat used to say that have you
killed anyone
rebel and vowel looked at me as if they
or i had been splashed in the face with
cold water what are you talking about
ellen oh you know the usual who's what
what's who heaven and hell let's go out
on the roof it's a flat surface it's
safe rebel and valve followed and they
asked what had gotten into me this is
the real me i announced waving my arms
above my head and then late on a friday
night on the roof of the yale law school
i began to sing and not quietly either
come to the florida sunshine bush do you
want to dance
are you on drugs when asked are you high
high me no way no drugs come to the
florida sunshine bush
where there are lemons where they make
demons you're frightening me one of them
said and rebel and val headed back into
the library
i shrugged and followed them
back inside i asked my classmates if
they were having the same experience of
words jumping around our cases as i was
i think someone's infiltrated my copies
of the cases i've said we've got to case
the joint i don't believe in joints but
they do hold your body together it's an
example of loose associations eventually
i made my way back to my dorm room and
once there i couldn't settle down my
head was too full of noise too full of
orange trees and law memos i could not
write and mass murders i knew i would be
responsible for
sitting on my bed
i rocked back and forth moaning in fear
and isolation
this episode led to my first
hospitalization in america i had two
earlier in england continuing with the
writings the next morning i went to my
professor's office to ask for an
extension on the memo assignment and i
began gibbering unintelligibly as i had
the night before and he eventually
brought me to the emergency room
once there someone i'll just call the
doctor and his whole team of goons
swooped down lifted me high into the air
and slammed me down on a metal bed with
such force that i saw stars then they
strapped my legs and arms to the metal
bed with thick leather straps
a count sound came out of my mouth that
i'd never heard before half grown half
scream
barely human and pure terror then the
sound came again forced from somewhere
deep inside my belly and scraping my
throat raw
this incident resulted in my involuntary
hospitalization
one of the reasons the doctors gave her
fine for hospitalizing me against my
will was that i was quote gravely
disabled to support this view they wrote
in my chart that i was unable to do my
yale law school homework i wondered what
that meant about much of the rest of new
haven
during the next year i would spend five
months in a psychiatric hospital at
times i spent up to 20 hours in
mechanical restraints
arms tied arms and legs tied down arms
and legs tied down with a net tied
tightly across my chest
i never struck anyone i never harmed
anyone i never made any direct threats
if you've never been restrained yourself
you may have a benign
image of the experience there's nothing
benign about it
every week in the united states it's
been estimated that one to three people
die in restraints
they strangle they aspirate their vomit
they suffocate they have a heart attack
it's unclear whether using mechanical
restraints is actually saving lives or
costing lives
while i was preparing to write my
student note for the yale law journal on
mechanical restraints i consulted an
eminent law professor who was also a
psychiatrist and said surely he would
agree that restraints must be degrading
painful and frightening he looked at me
in a knowing way and said
ellen you don't really understand these
people are psychotic they're different
from me and you they wouldn't experience
restraints as we would
i didn't have the courage to tell him in
that moment that no we're not that
different from him we don't like to be
strapped down to a bed and left to
suffer for hours any more than he would
in fact until very recently and i'm sure
some people still hold it as the view
that restraints help psychiatric
patients feel safe
i've never met a psychiatric patient who
agreed with that view
today i like to say i'm very
pro-psychiatry but very anti-force i
don't think force is effective as
treatment and i think using force is a
terrible thing to do to another person
with a terrible illness
eventually i came to los angeles to
teach at the university of southern
california law school for years i had
resisted medication making many many
efforts to get off
i felt that if i could manage without
medication i could prove that after all
i wasn't really mentally ill it with
some terrible mistake my motto was the
less medicine the less effective
my la analyst dr kaplan was urging me
just to stay on medication and get on
with my life but i decided i wanted to
make one last college try to get off
quoting from the text
i started the reduction of my beds and
within a short time
i began feeling the effects after
returning from a trip to oxford i
marched into kaplan's office headed
straight for the corner crouched down
covered my face and began shaking all
around me i sensed evil beings poised
with daggers they'd slice me up in thin
slices or make me swallow hot coals
kaplan would later describe me as quote
writhing in agony
even in this state what he accurately
described as acutely and floridly
psychotic i refuse to take more
medication
the mission is not yet complete
immediately after the appointment with
kaplan i went to see dr martyr a
schizophrenia expert who was following
me for medication side effects he was
under the impression that i had a mild
psychotic illness
once in his office i sat on his couch
folded over and began muttering head
explosions and people trying to kill is
it okay if i totally trash your office
you need to leave if you think you're
gonna do that said martyr
okay small fire on ice tell them not to
kill me tell them not to kill me what
have i done wrong hundreds of thousands
with thoughts interdiction
ellen do you feel like you're dangerous
to yourself or others
i think you need to be in the hospital i
could get you admitted right away and
the whole thing could be very discreet
you're offering to put me in hospitals
hospitals are bad they're mad they're
sad one must stay away
i'm god or i used to be at that point in
the text where i said i'm god or i used
to be my husband made a marginal note he
said did you quit or were you fired
i give i give life and i take it away
forgive me for i know not what i do
eventually i broke down in front of
friends and everybody convinced me to
take more medication i could no longer
deny the truth and i could not change it
the wall that kept me ellen professor
sacks separate from that insane woman
hospitalized year past years past like
smashed into ruins
everything about this illness says i
shouldn't be here but i am and i am i
think for three reasons first i've had
excellent treatment four to five day a
week psycho island looks psychotherapy
for decades and continuing in excellent
psychopharmacology
second i have many close family members
and friends who know me and know my
illness these relationships have given
my life a meaning and a depth and they
also help me navigate my life and fate
in the face of symptoms
third i work at an enormously supportive
workplace at usc law school
it this is a place that not only
accommodates my needs but actually
embraces them it's also a very
intellectually stimulating place and
occupying my mind with complex problems
has been my best and most uh powerful
and most reliable defense against my
mental illness
even with all that excellent treatment
wonderful family and friends supported
work environment i did not make my
illness public until relatively late in
life and that's because the stigma
against mental illness is so powerful
that i didn't feel safe with people
knowing
if you hear nothing else today please
hear this
there are not schizophrenics there are
people with schizophrenia and these
people may be your spouse they may be
your child they may be your neighbor
they may be your friend they may be your
co-worker
so let me share some final thoughts
we need to invest more resources into
research and treatment of mental illness
the better we understand these illnesses
the better the treatments we can provide
and the better the treatments we can
provide the more we can offer people
care and not have to use force
also we must stop criminalizing mental
illness it's a national tragedy and
scandal that the la county jail is the
biggest psychiatric facility in the
united states
american prisons and jails are filled
with people who suffer from severe
mental illness and many of them are
there because they never received
adequate treatment i could have easily
ended up there or on the streets myself
a message to the entertainment industry
and to the press
on the whole you've done a wonderful job
fighting stigma and prejudice of many
kinds
please continue to let us see characters
in your movies your plays your columns
who suffer with severe mental illness
portray them sympathetically and portray
them in all the richness and depth of
their experience as people and not as
diagnoses
recently a friend posed a question if
there were a pill i could take that
would instantly cure me would i take it
the poet reiner mary rielke was offered
psychoanalysis he declined saying don't
take my devils away because my angels
may flee too
my psychosis on the other hand is a
waking nightmare in which my devils are
so terrifying that all my angels have
already fled
so would i take the medic the pill in an
instant
that said i don't wish to be seen as
regretting the life i could have had if
i'd not been mentally ill nor am i
asking anyone for their pity what i
rather wish to say is that the humanity
we all share is more important than the
mental illness we may not what those of
us who suffer with mental illness want
is what everybody wants in the words of
sigmund freud to work into love thank
you
[Applause]
thank you
thank
thank
you